LEE JAE-YONG:
This is Lee Jae-Yong, known to the western
world as Jay Y. Lee.
Jay is the grandson of the great Lee Byung-chul,
the founder of Samsung.
Normally, these type of people are lazy spoiled
brats but not Jay.
He’s actually done a lot grow Samsung.
In fact, you could say that he’s the guy
who made Samsung into the multi hundred billion
juggernaut that they are today.
But, this sort of wealth and power didn’t
come clean.
It was the result of massive amounts of corruption.
In fact, Jay was so corrupt that he got sentenced
to prison twice.
The first was a 5 year jail centence for bribery
and embezzlement and the second was a 2.5
year sentence for bribery.
Being the second richest man in Korea, I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that Jay
didn’t end up spending all that much time
in prison but that was completely fine.
The prosecution’s main goal wasn’t to
put Jay behind bars to but to remove him from
power, and publicly exposing him did exactly
that.
For over 5 years, it seemed that the era of
Jay Y Lee’s Samsung was officially over.
But out of nowhere, in August of 2022, South
Korean President Yoon Suk Yeol would pardon
Jay.
And just two months later, Jay would return
to Samsung as chairman, a position that he’s
held ever since.
Now, you might be jumping out of your seat
to blame President Yoon Suk Yeol.
Of course, he’s just another bought out
politician that’s controlled by the super
rich.
Now, that could very well be true but what
I can say is that the president didn't act
alone.
You see, it was actually at America’s request
that President Yeol decided to pardon Jay.
So, here’s the story of Jay’s insane rise
to power, his humiliating fall from grace,
and his unexpected return to the throne.
RISE TO POWER:
Taking a look back, the story of Jay dates
back to June 23, 1968 to Seoul, South Korea.
At the time, Samsung was already a thriving
business involved in a variety of industries
from grocery exports and textiles to insurance,
security, and retail.
But, while Samsung was already successful,
they had yet to even enter the industries
that they’re most known for today: electronics
and appliances.
And it would end up being Jay’s father,
Lee Kun Hee, who would lead this evolution
making him the chosen heir within the Samsung
family.
Jay on the other hand was just a small boy
during all of this who was slowly working
his way through the school system.
I don’t think you’d be surprised to hear
that Jay ended up attending the prestigious
Seoul National University, the same university
that Sang Woo attended, where he majored in
East Asian history.
He followed this up with an MBA from Keio
University before attending Harvard where
he spent 5 years trying to get a PhD in Business
Administration.
Unfortunately though, he would never end up
finishing and just stuck to the family business
which he joined in 1991.
Speaking of joining the family business, let’s
just say that he had a royal welcome as he
would join directly as Vice President of Strategic
Planning at age 23.
And shortly after this, he would be promoted
to Chief Customer Officer, a C suite position
that was created specifically for Jay.
Obviously, Jay largely benefited from nepotism
but that isn’t to say that Jay wasn’t
talented in his own right.
After all, it’s not like all of Samsung’s
heirs have ended up as pivotal as Jay even
though they all got cushy executive positions.
And the main reason for this is that Jay chose
to focus on the right sector of Samsung.
His sister, Lee Boo Jin for example, went
down the hospitality path and became the CEO
of Hotel Shilla, a luxury Korean hotel chain
associated with Samsung.
Similarly, his other sister, Lee Seo Hyun,
went down the philanthropy route and became
the leader of Samsung’s welfare foundation.
Our boy Jay, however, had bigger ambitions
and knew exactly where the future lay: electronics.
This came in the form of 3 separate breakthroughs
starting with memory chips.
In 1999, Samsung would develop the world’s
first 1 gb NAND flash and they would follow
this up with a ground breaking pace of innovation.
2 gb in 2002, 4 gb in 2003, 8 gb in 2004,
16 gb in 2005, 32 gb in 2006, and 64 gb in
2007.
Combine this rapid innovation with Samsung’s
resources, power, and connections, and I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that Samsung
would end up as the king of memory.
This would end up being really important as
this business is what would eventually bail
Jay out of jail.
But this was just the beginning of Jay’s
contributions at Samsung.
His next big contribution was TVs.
Samsung didn’t necessarily create TVs that
were better than the competition but what
they did do was market TVs better than the
competition.
They attended all these tech events where
they showed off massive TVs, stupidly high
resolutions, and a bunch of marketing gimmicks.
This included things like 3d tvs, curved tvs,
OLED, QLED, neo QLED and who knows what else.
This isn’t to say that all of these technology
were just gimmicks.
OLED for example is awesome technology but
what really sold this technology was Samsung’s
phenomenal marketing which has given them
the number 1 spot in the TV market for the
past 17 years, and at the helm of all of it
was Jay.
But if you thought memory and TVs were big,
you probably forgot that Samsung also dominates
another industry: smartphones.
I don’t even think this one needs an explanation.
Samsung has sold over 2 billion Galaxies itself.
And according to Samsung, Jay has made invaluable
contributions to these sectors of Samsung.
So, it’s no wonder why Jay was next in line
to take over the company but there would be
a pretty big scare before this actually happened.
LIKE FATHER LIKE SON:
In 2008, Jay’s father, Lee Kun-hee, would
resign from his position as chairman.
Normally, this would be great news.
Lee had just completed a legendary run as
Samsung’s chairman and was retiring to make
way for younger generations right?
Well, that’s not exactly how this played
out.
Lee didn’t resign because he wanted to retire.
He resigned because he was forced to retire.
You see, Lee was indicted on charges of tax
evasion, and he would end up with a 3 year
suspended sentence along with a $109 million
fine.
This itself was terrible publicity for Samsung
but what they were really worried about was
a potential political crisis.
Prosecutors were also alleging that Samsung
had bribed influential South Korean politicians,
prosecutors, and bureacrats.
And if this was proven in court, that would
truly be a disaster.
Looking to avoid this, Lee and several of
his executives would resign which got the
prosecutors to back off and drop the bribery
charges.
But while Lee was able to leave the situation
pretty clean, the same could not be said about
Jay.
Lee had tarnished the family name making it
very difficult for Jay to ever takeover the
company.
But, this duo wasn’t gonna go down so easily.
What they had to do was clear the family name
and they were willing to go to any length
to do so including bribing the president of
South Korea: Lee Myung Bak.
Also, this isn’t just speculation or something.
Lee Myung Bak would eventually be sentenced
to 15 years in prison, partially for accepting
this bribe and pardoning Lee Kun-hee.
I think it’s safe to say that the former
president regretted accepting this bribe but
the same cannot be said about Lee Kun-hee.
In 2010, Lee would return to Samsung as chairman
as a pardoned man making the bribe quite worth
it.
And now that Lee was back in charge, his son
was also in the good graces of the company
who would make Jay vice chairman in 2012.
As you can see, these mega companies and their
leaders have a billion different way to get
out of any situation.
You get charged with tax evasion?
No problem.
You get charged with bribery?
No problem?
Obviously, you don’t wanna follow their
footsteps when it comes to any of these illicit
activities.
But one aspect we can learn from is how these
companies are dealing with the high inflation
high interest rate environment and their secret
is US treasury bills.
All of the biggest companies in the world
own tens of billions if not hundreds of billions
of dollars worth of US treasury bills including
Warren Buffett.
And this is not surprising given that treasurys
are paying out historically high yields of
over 5%.
We wanted everyday people to be able to take
advantage of these high yields just like these
companies are doing, and that’s why we created
Silo, a modern bond investing platform.
With Silo, you can invest in corporate and
government bonds all with the protection of
$500,000 in SIPC insurance and $2.5 million
in FDIC insurance.
So, if you would like to lock in high yields
for yourself from the comfort of your phone,
please consider checking out our bond investing
platform Silo in the description below.
But anyway, while Lee was able to yeet out
of jail time, something he couldn’t yeet
out of was health concerns.
In 2014, Lee would suffer a heart attack and
though he did recover, this event would basically
make Jay the de facto chairman of Samsung
leading us into his own foray with the law.
Given his family’s history, Jay was probably
involved in several shady activities over
the years but the crime that got him arrested
was bribery of another South Korean president:
Park Geun-hye.
It turns out that Jay had offered $38 million
worth of bribes to the presidents friends
and acquaintances to push through a merger.
Samsung had no choice but to admit that they
had indeed handed over this money but they
would insist that it was merely a good faith
donation and that Jay had no idea that these
people were connected to the president.
That was obviously complete and utter BS and
unsurprisingly, Jay would be found guilty
of perjury, embezzlement, and bribery leading
to a 5 year prison sentence.
Something else that isn’t surprising is
that Jay never ended up spending 5 years in
prison.
After spending 1 year in prison, the Seoul
High Court would magically reduce his sentence
to 2.5 years and suspend it, meaning that
he was let go.
Unfortunately for Jay though, the Supreme
Court of South Korea would end up ordering
a retrial which resulted in another 2.5 year
prison sentence for Jay in early 2021.
By this point, Jay had already pulled all
the strings he could to minimize his stay
in prison and all he could do was just put
his head down and serve his sentence.
That was until America decided to get involved.
RETURN TO THE THRONE:
If you’ve been following the tech world,
you’re probably familiar with the chip shortage
that we went through recently.
Whether you were buying a Tesla or a regular
old refrigerator, you often had to wait several
months or even more than an year just to get
your product.
And the main reason for this was the supply
chain shortage, and more specifically, the
chip shortage.
On one side, this was great for businesses
as they could jack up prices and capitalize
on limited supply.
But on the other hand, they were missing out
on a lot of demand simply because they couldn’t
meet the demand.
Not to mention, all of this was making President
Joe Biden look pretty bad.
So, America turned to Samsung and TSMC to
fix this issue.
Unfortunately for them though, Lee Kun-hee
would pass away in late 2020 meaning that
Samsung needed a new leader to navigate this
supply chain crisis.
And who better for the job than the prodigy
son with shady ethics: Jay Y Lee.
How could they get Jay out of prison though?
Easy, by leveraging the largest lobbying group
in America: the United States Chamber of Commerce.
If you’re wondering who funds this lobbying
group, well, they don’t disclose their donors,
but some companies are transparent about their
affiliation.
This includes the likes of FedEx, Facebook,
Microsoft, Cheron, Comcast, Ford, and Pfizer.
So, yeah, a pretty powerful group.
And in 2021, these guys would approach South
Korean president Yoon Suk Yeol with “a proposal”
to solve the global chip shortage.
This plan started off by getting Jay out of
prison in August of 2021 on parole, just 7
months after he was sentenced for the second
time.
This parole, however, came along with a 5
year restriction on business activities, so
Jay couldn’t just immediately return to
Samsung but that was ok.
It was better for Jay to lay low for a while
and wait for people to forget before returning
anyway.
And that’s exactly what would happen.
12 months after getting released, President
Yoon Suk Yeol would pardon Jay in August of
2022.
His reasoning was that Jay was simply too
important to the Korean economy to be kept
in jail.
Outraged by this pardon, activists would protest
on the streets but this didn’t stop Jay
from returning as chairman in October of 2022.
Since then, memory chip prices have fallen
off a cliff as much 53% actually.
In fact, memory chip prices have fallen so
much that Samsung’s own profits have fallen
by 95% within just 1 year.
Is this because of some strings that Jay pulled
or just a result of the market naturally correctly?
We may never know but this doesn’t really
matter for Jay or the lobbyists because things
played out just fine for them.
And that’s how a convict ended up as the
new chairman of Samsung.
Jay may be back but he’s definitely feeling
the pain of falling memory chip prices and
more importantly the era of peak smartphone.
Check out this video to learn more.